Hello world,
it's Raj.
And today I'm going to show you how to
build your own self driving car in a
simulated environment. And it's actually
much simpler than what we've been doing.
Like so recall we've been talking about
generative adversarial networks and
variational auto encoders and
all sorts of stochastic models.
This comparatively is
actually surprisingly simple,
which is crazy if you think about it,
a self driving car, it's simple. No,
but it actually is.
It's nine lines of chaos.
I mean the model itself is
and then the helper code.
But we're going to talk about how you
can build this and I'm going to show you
step by step the entire process. Okay? So
here's an example of what it looks like,
uh,
when it's,
when it's fully trained and it's
running in the simulated environment.
So I'm super excited.
I hope you are.
And at the end I'm going to answer some
questions just straight up from youtube
comments. So I'm excited for
this. Let's, let's get started.
So the first thing we want to do,
I'm going to stop this. A demo.
This is what it's eventually
going to look like.
And now the car's going to crash into
the water because I turned off the
autonomous feature. Oh, let me
just turn off the simulator. Okay.
Simulator is gone.
Okay.
So let's first go ahead and talk about
what this is and what the whole deal is
behind all of this. A little bit of theory
and then we'll get back into the code.
Okay. So where are we? Where
are we? There we are. Okay.
So how does simulate a self driving
car is the name of this tutorial.
And so you Udacity recently
open source their simulators.
So they built a simulator specifically
for self driving cars. So cool. Right?
It's just for self driving
cars. Uh, and it was,
it was built for their self driving
car and inner degree students and they
recently open sourced it. So,
uh, it was built with unity,
which is if you haven't used unity before,
I would definitely recommend at least
checking it out. If I had more time,
I would definitely be diving into unity
and building all sorts of cool three d
models that I could play with.
And you know,
maybe even generating three
models with generative models. Uh,
but yeah, it's, it's, it's a great tool.
It's very much using in virtual reality
and more and more in machine learning
for, for modeling and things like that.
But definitely check it out. But yeah,
they built this thing in unity and uh,
they added a bunch of prebuilt scripts.
They added a bunch of scripts and the
scripts a control things like gravity and
momentum and acceleration and all sorts
of things that you would think would be
in a self driving car simulation.
And you can modify these things as well
as they're just values that you could
just change in code.
Uh,
but you can find that the actual
simulator itself right here on get hub,
and I'll also have a link to it in the
description and in the get hub read meat.
But it's a binary file.
You don't have to compile it from source.
That is like an exe, you
know, you just download it.
It's like a dot hap file and you
can just download it for Linux,
Mac and windows and then boom, you're
good to go. And it's got two modes.
It's got a training mode
and an autonomous mode.
And I'll talk about what each
of those modes is, but the,
the high level is you just
download it and it just works.
No dependencies to install or anything.
So it's super, super simple. Okay.
So that's what they built.
And so let's talk about the three
step process and how this works. Okay.
There's a data generation part,
then there's a training part
and then there's a testing part.
So the first part is the data generation
park. And so what happens is, uh,
we are going to first
look at what Nvidia did.
So to generate data.
What nvidia did was they took their,
they took a car and they did the same
exact thing that we're going to do.
We're going to replicate what Nvidia and
you, Udacity did. It's the same thing.
They built a nine layer convolutional
network and the attached three cameras to
the head of a car.
Okay?
So the attached three cameras to the
head of a car and they had a human driver
drive the car while the cameras were
attached and all the car had to do with
collect data and buy data.
I mean the steering, uh, let
me turn off the sound here.
The steering commands that the,
that the human driver was inputting
as well as the camera feed.
So the three sets of camera images coming
from, from all three cameras. Okay.
At the same time. And that was
the data generation park. Okay.
And so there were,
there was images from the center left
and right cameras with the Associated
Steering Angle, speed, throttle and brake.
So there were four of physics variables
as well as the static images that were
coming in. And it saves it all to a
CSV, which is what we're going to do.
And ideally, ideally you have
a joystick for this thing,
but I don't have a joystick.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
And just because it's
like, it's easier, it's,
it's smoother with the transitions and
stuff using a keyboard that wasd keys.
It's kind of erratic, but whatever.
I mean it works. It works.
What you thought was based
off of a keyboard training.
So whatever it works. Uh,
so yeah,
so that's where the data generation
part and then there's the training part.
Okay. So what the I, the idea is
that we have a human driver. Okay.
So the human driver is just driving around
and we're reporting all that data and
then we're going to get a
machine to clone that behavior.
So we call this process behavioral
cloning. Okay. Behavioral cloning.
And to do this, we're going to build
a nine layer convolutional network,
nine layers. And in chaos, that's
just literally nine lines of code.
And it was based off of Nvidia's end to
end learning for self driving car paper.
And Yeah.
So they trained a model for 72 hours
on the whole book in a whole bunch of
different driving conditions, sleep,
rain, hail, all, all sorts of things.
Wet Rain, you know, everything.
So here's the hardware design.
So the hardware design was,
it's obviously a steering wheel,
but the steering wheel is attached to a
controller. What was that? What was the,
uh, so many acronyms here. Could
the controller area network bus.
And so it's feeding in those four
variables that I talked about. Right.
And you're also have your three cameras
and the three cameras are all feeding in
continuous streams,
like just frame by frame of all the
images that the car is seeing and it's fed
into this drive px, a computer, which is
essentially like a motherboard with us,
a cluster of genes onboard,
gps attached to it, and then a,
and then a solid state storage would
just store the results. That's it. Okay.
So that's the, that's the high level
idea behind the hardware behind it.
And then the software behind it. Oh,
and also a interesting little tidbit,
I just report it from the paper.
Instead of inputting the
steering command are directly,
they inputted one over r and they found
that this may turn smoother and it made
the, it made the, uh,
autonomous angles at the car moved
independent of the geometry of the car.
So the car was facing left,
it didn't matter or the conversation,
right. It's all about what the cameras is,
what the camera's c and then using that
as the signal to then move the steering
ankle.
So it's,
it's independent of the direction of
the car is facing and it sounds kind of
counterintuitive. Like wait, you would
want that but you actually wouldn't end.
We'll learn more about why that
is as we get into this code. Okay.
So the software designed for this code
and it's so crazy cause going from
generative adversarial networks to this.
It's like that's it.
That's all it takes for self
driving car. Like what? But that's,
that is actually how it is.
Check this out. So here's,
here's, here's what happens.
We have, uh, we have two inputs, right?
We have our steering angle and then we
have our sets of cameras, right? Let's,
so three sets of images.
Those are our inputs. And so
we can think of the problem as a
supervised learning problem, right?
We have our input data,
which is,
which are the images and then
our output labels, which are the,
if we could just abstract all of the
steering angles and one value, you know,
like one binary value that would be
our label. Like based on what you see,
how should you move the
car? That's it, right?
So we have a CSV just listed
and all of those things, right?
And at the same time we have uh,
what the car is trying to do.
So during the training process,
assuming we've generated data 72,
let's say 72 hours of human generated
driving data, we can then, uh,
compare the,
both of those results together so we can
compute the error or lost between the
two. Right? So if we have,
let's just say we have the camera
angles and the steering wheel from the
autonomous car and then the camera angles
and the steering wheel variable from
the human generated data.
And then we just vectorize both
of those values into one value.
And then we find a difference between
those values and that difference is our
error.
And then we use backpropagation to then
update our weights based on that error
value. Okay. So it's taking that,
that weight value or that back,
that air value and in back
propagating it in our weights. Okay.
So images are images are fed into the
CNN and then it computes a proposed
steering committee. Okay. And that
is the predicted steering command.
And we want to find a difference between
the predicted steering command and what
the actual steering command would
be from the training data. Okay. Uh,
and then the proposed command is
compared to the desired command, right?
Label the target label
versus the actual outputs.
And then the weights of the CNN are
adjusted to bring the CNN output closer to
the desired output.
And the way that adjustment is
accomplished via backpropagation.
So eventually you want, it's trained,
then all you're going to need is,
is the center camera, just one camera,
you feed it to the, to the CNN,
and then it outputs a prediction.
And the prediction is the angle of the
steering wheel, just one output. Right?
So that's it for training and then for
testing, right? So once, once we've,
once we've trained this autonomous model
for testing, we could think of it in,
in terms of a simulator as a
server client architecture, right?
The server is going to be the simulator
itself. That is our, you know,
the APP that we downloaded that,
that little three d game and the client
is going to be our python program that
what we write and what it's going to do
is it's going to just be a feedback loop.
It's going to be a feedback loop
so we can consider it as just,
so this is how we can consider it.
It's just the client is piping in steering
angles and throttles to the server
and the server is piping back,
uh,
images from the car and steering
angles so that it can train it, right?
It's just that it's just a, it's
just a feedback loop. So that's,
that's the basic idea behind, you know,
how this works. High level and video,
have the paper on it and
then you, Udacity, you know,
was inspired by it and now
I'm bringing it to you guys.
So it's just the chain of a chain of
whatever. Okay, so let's build this thing,
right enough talk,
let's go this thing.
So that's the first step is
to install our dependencies.
And you can do this really easily
with just one line of code.
There's an environments dot
yml file and you can use
Anaconda to do this. Okay?
So if we look in the environments file,
we've got like 20 dependencies here,
but you don't have to, you know, as
long as you run this one line of code,
it's going to install all of these
dependencies. I make this bigger,
all of these dependencies
super easily. Okay? So yeah,
you've got open CV, which we all know
is a pain to install. So luckily for us,
Anaconda is going to make it
super easy to install. Okay?
So that's the first step.
Now, I would do this myself,
but I've already installed
the dependency here. Uh,
but what I can do, right? So you just
paste that in and once you paste that in,
then you're going to type in, I can
show you the command. You say source,
activate. What was the
command? I'll put it in the,
I'll put it in the get how breathing,
but you then you activate your conda
environment and it's gonna be called
behavioral cloning. Source
activate, behavioral cloning.
And then that activates the environment.
So you install your dependencies in
this container, this Anaconda container,
and then you activate it.
So then all those dependencies are then
active in that Shell, in that session,
in terminal. Okay. And so once we have
that, then we can generate our data. Okay.
Where we've got our dependencies.
Now, step two is to generate our data.
So this is, it's a five step process.
We're going to install our dependencies,
which we assume I've done.
Step two is to generate the data.
So we're going to drive and
we're going to replicate,
replicate what the Nvidia
did with the human drivers.
Step three is to write the training
script, step forwards to train it.
Then have our agents learn or clone
the behavior of us, the human.
And step five is to write the testing
scripts and then let it run. Okay?
So let's go ahead and generate our data.
So to generate our data,
we're going to have to actually drive
this baby, which is gonna be a lot of fun.
Now you just double click on the
APP, you know, I downloaded it,
you can double click on it
and then you know, it's got,
it's got a couple of settings I sent
it to. Fantastic because why not?
Of course the choice, uh, but
uh, you know, fastest, you know,
depending on your processor, you,
you would want to change this.
So I'm going to go ahead and run
it at 800 by 600 and it's gonna,
it's gonna pop up just like that. And
I'm going to go into training mode. Okay.
So for training, for training mode,
I'll just click on training mode.
And the controls are going to be w a
s. D. Okay. So just like this, see,
this is me driving right now.
Hi, I'm driving the car. Okay.
And now I'm going to stop the car
and I'm driving it again. Okay.
So this is human driving.
So what we're going to do is we're going
to generate data so that we can train
our, our car on that data. Okay? So
to do this, we just have to type in,
just type our right to record are.
And so then it's going to ask, well,
where do you want to save this data too?
And I'm going to say let's
save it to the desktop. Okay,
let's save it to the
desktop and start recording.
And now what it's doing is it is
reporting three sets of images from three
virtual cameras of the car. Okay?
Assume that the cameras are on top,
but what it's doing is it's capturing
frames from this game from three different
angles. And it's also recording the, my,
the four variables I talked
about speed, throttle, and the,
the other two of the steering angle.
There's one more that I'll look at,
but basically what you want to do as
you train this thing is you want to
complete either one between
one and five laps. Okay?
Ideally five. But, and look, I'm off
track, but let me just stop recording.
And so then once you're done, you know,
driving between one and five laps,
then hit our again and it's
going to capture that data.
So it's going to replay what you've
just done and it's going to go up to a
hundred percent and when it's done,
it's going to save it all to a CSV file
that we're going to look at and see
what's inside of there
so we could observe it.
So we've got 52% and in the meantime,
let me go to the CSV file and
show you guys that. What else?
What else can I show you
while this captures? Well,
it's actually fun to just watch this.
Let me see what else I can talk about the
training and testing script. Uh, yeah,
we're going to be using carrots 95% here
we go. Done. Okay, let's check it out.
What if,
what did we save here?
So if I go to open and then
I go to my desktop there,
my driving log, just just like
we thought it would be. Okay.
So let's take a look at what this is.
Let's take a look at what this is.
What we've got here are three images,
right?
And it's the three columns are images,
they're pointing to images.
And these are the images that it's
pointing to right here, this image folder.
Okay? They're pointing their
absolute, uh, directory values.
It shows us exactly where they are.
See,
these are the images that they're
pointing to, just like that.
And then these are frames that
were captured from the game.
And we've got three sets of images
for the center for the left.
And these are labeled with
the direction and the right.
So we've got three sets of images
and then we've got four values here.
And these four values are those
values that I talked about up here,
which are the,
which ones are they?
The steering angle, the speed, the
throttle, and the brake. All four values.
And these are what I inputted and
see how at the start I wasn't moving.
So these are, these are zero
values, but then as I start moving,
they're going to change. Okay. So
that's it. That's it for our data.
So what you want to do is
write training between one run,
one full lap and five laps. Okay, so
somewhere in between there. So yes,
that's, that's it for our
uh, data generation part.
Where were we in our process?
We were at step two. So assume that I've
generated data. Okay. Just like that.
It would take a while,
but I generated data.
So the next step is for us
to write our training script.
So let's write this training
script. Okay. So where were we
for our training script?
I'm going to say,
okay, so we've got two files
here. We've got a training script,
which is modeled up high, and then we've
got a testing script called Dr Puy. Well,
let's write our training scripts,
right?
We've generated our data and
we've saved it to the desktop.
And now we want to build a model that
will see a convolutional network and we'll
read from this data and then it will
output output steering commands.
So we've got pandas. Pandas is going
to be our data analysis to toolkits.
None Pie's going to help us do matrix
math. We're going to import psychic,
can't learn just so we can split our
training and testing data into sets into
sets.
And then we're going to use care os as
our machine learning model sequential
because it's going to be a linear
stack of layers. Very simple model.
And then Adam for gradient descent model
checkpoints. So we could save our model.
And then we've got a mid layer
types that we're going to use.
Then our helper class utils it's going
to define our input shape and generate
training images and then our, our cars
for command line arguments. And lastly,
r o s module for reading files.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
write the code for building the model
itself. Uh, but all of all the
rest of it is prewritten, right?
So the data loading parts are prewritten.
We're going to load that CSV
file that we just created, right?
That driving log and make it bigger,
make it bigger. So that driving log,
we're going to,
we're going to generate that data or
we're going to read from that data using
pandas and then we're going to say,
okay,
so now we have that in a data frame
variable, very easily possible variable.
Thank you pandas. Then we're going to
say for the center left and right, uh,
columns get those values and that this
is going to be our input data that's
going to be our x,
right?
And then are a output data is going to
be our steering commands. So we can,
we can can catenate that
into one variable, right?
So then we have our input data and our
input and our output labels and we want
to find the mapping between the two and
it says a supervised learning problem.
And once we find the mapping between
the two, then given novel input data,
which is novel a camera
images of what a car sees,
we can then output the predicted label,
which will be the Syrian command
c very intuitive. Right. Okay.
So we've got our input data and our output
labels and then we can split the data
into training and testing data.
So it's 80% training, 20% testing,
and we can define the size of that in
our command line argument and test size.
Okay, we're just going to be a point
to oh, this is going to be this value.
And so yeah,
so we're going to have a training,
our training data and our testing data
and our validation data and we returned
that. Okay, so, and then we've got
the code for building our model, uh,
and then training the model and
then the main function, right?
So let's forget about these
command line arguments.
So let's just go straight to the main
function and let's say that for our main
function after printing, you
know, whatever our parameters are,
we're going to load our
data using that funk,
that function that we just talked about.
And then we're going to
take that data and use it to
train our model and look
first we'll build our model.
And then once we built our model and
loaded our data, we'll train our model,
right? Using those two parameters as
well as any command line arguments.
So this committee,
this helper function just
as for converting a string
to a boolean value for our
command line argument. But this training
model function is really interesting. Uh,
let's first build a model and
then we'll talk about the, uh,
the training model function.
Okay. So for this first part,
we're going to build this model and it's
going to be a sequential model, right?
It's going to be sequential model,
very simple model.
And we can just pull this
straight from the paper it's,
or even the paper write the paper told
us the parameters with which we could
build our network.
So we'll use those parameters,
we'll use those parameters
to build our network.
So the first step is for us to say,
okay,
we want our first layer to be an
image normalization layer. Okay,
we can totally do that.
Our image normalization layer using our
lambda function and the land of function
is going to help us do so really
easily. And we'll say, okay,
it's going to be,
let me type this out and then I'll
talk about it. Input, shape. Okay,
so what's the deal here?
So x exited.
Yeah.
So this is going to avoid saturation
and make our grants work better.
Now notice that these are magic
number's right here. Uh, but we,
but the authors found that,
you know,
after training and testing
out different values,
these are the ones that work best
for normalizing the images, right?
When we input it to avoid saturation and
make the gradients worked at or what do,
what do we mean exactly by that is,
you know,
the images can be shadowy, they can,
you know, depending on the lighting,
it can be certain things can be
obstructed or the hue or that, you know,
all of these color correction values could
be off and they could give us results
that are bad. So we went to avoid
that, right? So that's that. When we,
when we say image normalization,
what we really mean is we want to format
or reshape these image tensor values
and two values that will give us
good predictions in the end. Right?
So that's it for our first model.
And then we've got a bunch
of convolutional layers
that we can essentially
copied it.
Copy and paste ones who've written
out the first one because they're very
similar. And so the first one is going
to have a filter size of 24. Okay,
I got you. And it's got, it's going to
be a five by five convolution. Okay.
I can do that as well. And then it's
going to have an activation function,
which is going to be Elu, which means
exponential when your unit. So can,
we've got Elu here. Okay. Which is
more suited for this task
then rectified linear units.
And we're going to sub sample with two
by two because that's the length of our
strides. And then we'll add
our closing parentheses.
Okay. So that's it. Um, and
so why do we use the loo?
Is it's because it takes care of the
vanishing gradient problem. That's why.
So okay. So we've got five
of these layers. Let me just
paste that one, two, three,
four. How many of these five I think
that's fine. That's fine. Okay.
So then we want to make sure, okay,
so what's the difference here?
The filter size here is 36 this is how
you can just read from a paper and just
write out the model directly,
right? It's not that hard.
They have the parameters and with a
simple library like carrots, you can,
you can build a model pretty easily.
So we've got 36 we've got 48
64 okay.
And so then we can remove the sub sampling
for this, for these last two layers,
since the census, stride size is one
by one respectively for each of the,
for each of them.
So they'll just end in the activation
and then we're going to add a dropout
layer. Okay? So it's asking
for 50% dropout. We can do
that. So we'll say, okay,
drop out. We'll add it based on
what the user says it's going to be.
And we're going to,
it's going to,
we're going to input 50% later
and then we're going to say, okay,
so now that it's dropped out,
we're going to flatten the the data.
And so why do we thought flattened it?
Because we're going to start feeding in
a series of fully connected layers and y,
y,
y series of fully connected layers because
the convolutional layers are meant to
handle feature engineering. So that
means that the image processing part,
so the filters, right? So we,
we feed in a set of images and what the
convolutional layers we'll do is each of
them respectively is going
to create a set of filters.
And these filters are going to be, you
know, increasingly abstract, right?
So they're going to start off with low
level features and they're going to get
increasingly more extract. So they're
going to be able to detect images.
But what we want to output is
not an image, but we want to,
what it is that we want to output is a
value and that value is single value.
And that as the steering command,
the right, it's a direction.
How do you want to move this,
this wheel. So to do that,
to get a single value from these high
dimensional image tensors, we have to,
we have to squash that data.
And the way to do that is by applying a
series of fully connected layers. Okay.
And so what's gonna Happen is,
uh,
each of these fully connected layers is
going to progressively get smaller and
smaller in terms of the
number of neurons they have.
And you'll see what I mean here.
So it says the first one should have
a hundred neurons. So we'll say, okay,
so this is a dense,
which means fully connected layer and
it's activation function, like all the,
all the other layers
is going to be he Lou.
And so then what we can do is we can just
copy and paste this. I'll say one, two,
three. So there's going to
be four of them in total.
Each of them is going to be smaller.
So hundred neurons, 15 [inaudible],
10 neurons,
and then just a single neuron.
And this one won't have an activation
function because it's the last layer and
that's going to output are driving
a value our steering down and say,
okay, so it's a summary. And
so of all of those summer,
all those values to get the summary and
then return the model. Okay. And so then
we'll say,
how much do we have here that they're,
there we go and then return the model.
Okay, cool. So right, so for
our fully connected layers,
we start off with a big layer and then
we want to get progressively smaller.
And so the way to do that is by using a
model summary or by is by using a series
of fully connected layers
that get smaller and smaller.
And what that's going to do
is going to squash our data.
So it's going to basically be like a
triangle in terms of the number of values
in that,
in those matrices that are being
propagated forward in our network.
So it's gonna be like, you
know, uh, 10 uh, a matrix,
the matrix with 10 in indices and then
like a matrix matrix with five indices
and a matrix with two indices and
eventually one single scalar value.
And that is our output and that's
what this is going to do. Right.
And the wine in the paper,
they noted this, but I, I
didn't actually document this.
They noted that it's not sure where
the image part and the ND, uh,
steering part begin and end because it's
all kind of connected, right? In terms of
what the,
what the neural network looks like.
But that's part of the black
box magic of neural networks.
We don't know exactly where one feature
starts in one feature ends in terms of
where it lies in bs in this abstraction
hierarchy. But we know that all as a,
as a whole, as a sum total, there is
some, there is some connectedness, right?
So anyway, so that's it for our model.
And then once we have this model,
we're going to train the model.
And so let me talk about
this last training function.
So for the training function,
we're going to say, okay,
take the model and then the,
the training data and the validation data.
So modeling data and train
it, right? So to do this,
we're going to run the
model checkpoint function.
And what this does is it saves our model
at ace in a checkpoint that we bear,
that we,
Yep.
That we say that we want and it's gonna
be model dot h five and then we're going
to say, well, what is the loss function
that we want to monitor? We're,
which we're going to call
the validation loss. Not yet,
but we're going to call it that.
And
we only want to save the best model.
Okay?
And then we're going to say the mode is
going to be auto and automotive means
the direction is automatically inferred
from the name of the monitor quantity.
Okay? So that's it for our checkpoint.
And then we want to compile our models.
So what are we going to do
here? We're going to say, okay,
well what is our loss function are going
to be? Well, there are several laws,
assumptions that we can use and we're
going to use a really simple one called
mean squared error.
What does that mean?
So our model is going to output
a predicted a steering angle,
and then we have an actual steering
angle from the human driver given those
camera angles.
And then we want to find the difference
between those angles and do that for all
of the uh, data points that we have. Okay.
And then some of the differences.
And then, uh, hold on.
We want to find the difference.
Square, the difference, Adam,
all the differences and then
divide by the number of them.
And that's going to be the mean squared
error. The sum of the squared errors.
Okay. Or the mean of the
squared errors. Right. Uh,
and so then we're going to use the Adam
optimizer, which is gradient descent. Uh,
yeah.
And so that's how we compile our model
and then we're going to generate some
data. So what we're doing here is
we're running the fit generator. Okay.
And so what did fit generator does is it
lets you do realtime data augmentation
on images on the CPU in parallel
to training our model on the GPU.
What do we mean by that? What we are
generating batches of data. Okay.
While we are generating those batches
of data from, from our training data,
like the,
the,
the buckets or the containers from
which we train our model in from the,
from the huge set at the same
time we're actually, we're,
we're training our model,
right?
So what this fit generator function does
is it does both simultaneously. Okay.
So it's super valuable and then
cool.
So then we can train this
model, right? We just, we'll,
we'll run python model.py and
it'll start raining on our driving.
He'll start training on our driving
logs and we want to then, uh,
once it's training,
once it's done training,
we're going to write our testing scripts.
So training can take a while.
It depends on whether you're
using it on the CPU or the GPU,
if you're running it on the
cloud or on your local machine.
But training can take a while and we can
definitely speed it up by running it on
the GPU. I read this thing on my Mac book
and it took about eight hours to train.
So yeah, it all depends on what kind
of specification you have. Right?
So once we've, so assume that
we've trained it, it could,
it's going to take hours
and hours to train.
So we're not going to train it right now,
but as soon we've trained it,
then we can write our testing script.
Okay, so let's go to our testing code.
So let's check this out. So let's,
let's check out our testing code.
So for our testing code,
remember it is a server client model.
That's what we're using.
We're using a server client model
and that means that the uh, the,
that the simulator is the server and
then our client is then script that we're
writing. So we want to think
of it like a thing of it,
like a server client models.
We're going to use flasks to do this,
the web app framework.
So let me talk about the dependencies
and then we'll talk about the code.
So the first thing I want to do is
to find our command line arguments.
Base 64 is going to help us to code
camera images. They time for, uh,
for timestamps. Uh, what else? We
got high level file operations.
Socket io is going to help us work work
with this as a real time server in terms
of piping commands through event handlers.
We're going to use a vent lid
for concurrent networking.
Uh, and then we have uh,
more web framework dependencies and then
image manipulation with pillow flats
because our web framework and then bites,
I have to deal with input output and
of course care os it's just a load our
model and our help class. Okay. So we'll
start off by initializing our server.
Okay.
It's going to be a socket io server
and it's going to use flask to do this.
And we'll initialize our model and imagery
as empty because we're going to fill
those as we later on.
And then we're going to set a Max and
mins feed for our autonomous cars.
So it can't go faster than 25 miles an
hour and it can't go less than 10 miles
an hour. Uh, and then it's what we're
going to define a speed limit as well.
What are you going to
be at Max? Speed. Okay.
So then let me skip this function
because we're going to write it now.
Let me talk about that. The
other functions. So let's
go into this main function.
So these are the command line
arguments that defined, you know, what,
where is the model and
where are the images, uh,
that we want to wear. The images
from the runner going to be saved.
So we'll load the model using
our load function and then,
and we'll tell it via command line where
that model is and it's going to create
an image folder and then it can either
record the run or not depending on how we,
what we say. And then it's going
to launch this flask middleware,
which is going to let our client
communicate with the server and then we're
going to deploy it as a w s Gi
server, right? And the, that acronym,
what was it again?
It was w Sgi.
Let me brush up on my web, my web
stuff here. That'd be West Gi.
It's not crud create, read, update a
web server gateway interface, right?
We have 101 acronyms. Okay.
So what these functions are,
are, these are event handlers and this is
why we're using a socket io as a server
because behind under the
hood for the simulator,
it's got the, it's got the architecture
necessary to send commands that we need.
We just need to create event handlers
to then accept those commands, right?
So we don't have to code the server part,
we just have to close the client part.
So this is really the easiest way to
get started with building a self driving
car. This simulator that you'd ask
to be released is the easiest way.
Obviously there's grand theft auto,
which is awesome and stuff. Uh,
but you can only run that out if you're on
windows. And then also, you know, there,
it's got a whole bunch of extra features
that we don't necessarily need. Um,
but yeah, we could also do it
in grant that thought of it.
Right now this is the easiest,
if you're looking for the easiest way to
get started with building self driving
cars, this is the way. Okay. So, so
we have event handlers for connects,
which is going to just send a,
uh, the sid the session Id, uh,
and then we've got a send control.
We're just going to send the actual
commands that are model emits,
but then we have the telemetry function.
And so that is going to be the,
um, that's going to be the big
thick, the meat of our code.
And that's what we're gonna
write out here. Okay. So
we're going to write up this,
this part right here. So we're gonna say,
okay, so what this does is it's going to
make the prediction and then send it.
It's going to make the prediction of what
the steering angle is going to be and
then we're going to send it to the server.
Okay?
So let's go ahead and write this down.
So if data,
so we're going to feed this in our data
and then we're going to create an if
statement says if data. So once we
got our data as our, as our focus,
we're going to say,
let's get the current angle of the car.
So we'll say the steering angle. We want
the steering angle of the car. Okay,
so that's the first variable
that we want and it's going to,
we're going to retrieve it
from our data data frame. Okay.
And then we want the throttle. Okay?
So remember we want these variable,
we want these values so that we can
manipulate them and turn them into one
single scalar value that will
tell our car where to go.
And we want the speed and the
speed is going to be a float.
It's going to be a float value.
And just like the rest it's going to,
we're going to pull it from this
data frame using the Scott Key,
which is going to be speed,
human readable Qi.
And then we're going to get the current
image from the center of the camera for
the center camera of the car using
pillow, right? So say image of open.
So and then we'll use this word bites.
Io comes into play.
This is what we're using it because we
want to convert it from a 64 this image
into what we can read
directly into our model.
So we'll say base 64 d
code data and then image.
Okay. And so then we'll say, okay,
so once we have those things,
we'll go ahead and and do some
tensor processing on this image.
So we need to feed this image into
our network, right? So to do that,
to do that, we're going to say, image,
let's see what else do we
need here, image. And then
so we're going to convert the,
the image to an array and then we're going
to apply the preprocessing step to it.
And then the model is going to
expect a 40 array. So that's what,
that's what this image is going to be.
And so once we have that, then we can say,
then we can say, uh, predict the steering
angle for the car. Give them that image.
So we're going to say, okay, so
let's predict the steering angle.
Using our model was a model
that predicts just one line,
given the image and the batch
size, whichever, which is
whatever it's going to be.
Let's just say one for this simple
example. And then once we have that,
we're going to say, okay, so then given
the speed limit, that global value,
they'll be initialized.
It's greater than if the speed of the car
is greater than what we've said as our
speed. Then change it. Say, okay,
well the new speed limit is
going to be the men speed.
So then that means slow down, right?
And so else if it's not, then we'll,
then we can say the speed limit is
going to be the Max speed, right?
So we don't want it to go faster than the
speed limit is what we're saying here.
And once we've done that,
then we can say, okay,
the throttles going to be
1.0 minus the steering angle.
So this is a magic number territory.
This is where it guessing
and checking comes in,
what will say minus speed over speed limit
turns to George squared.
Okay.
And then we can send the control
using that helper function that we defined
before using the steering angle and
throttle. Cool. That's it
for this code. Right? So
that's it.
We profit,
we preprocess the image and then we fed
it into our model and then it outputs
the the steering angle and then we
can use that to then send that control
directly to the server. We have
the sand control function. Okay.
And it's going to admit that as a,
as a,
as a packet to the server and the server
will read that in. So the actual event,
the event handling logic is,
is written by the,
is under the hood for the simulator
and we can just send it via our client.
That's it. Okay. So then once we had that,
then we can compile it and it's going to
run the script just like I did right at
the beginning. All right, so to end this,
I'm going to answer three
questions randomly from the
youtube comments and then
we're out of here. Okay. So the
first question is, let's see what,
what kind of questions we got here,
how to work with multiple datasets.
This is a great question
and it's worthy of a video,
but essentially there are several
ways of thinking about this.
One way is you can just combine all your
data sets into one big dataset using
pandas. And that's what I would do.
That that's probably the best way.
That's the cleanest way.
But another way you could do it
is thinking about it serially.
So you'll want to train your model on
one dataset and then train your model on
the next Dataset. But I would, I would
just combine all your data sets into one,
two more questions that I'm going
to read from the comments. Um,
what else do we got here?
How can I discover a foreign language
like Russian? Do you tell me?
So this is for the language
translation of video.
So discovering a language is,
um,
quite a challenging task,
but think of it has associations.
So as long as you have some kind of
labels and the labels could be a different
language,
but maybe you're trying to discover an
ancient language or discover the rules of
some language you don't know, then as long
as you have some kind of associations,
you can treat it as a supervised
learning problem. Okay. And, uh,
I've got two language translation videos
and links to those in the description
of that video. And one more question. Um,
once you have this neural net training
can be optimized to run locally or does
it have to be run as is every time?
Yeah.
You can re optimize a network.
You can use the pre trained model or you
can use your card. You can retrain it.
Again,
it all depends.
You can retrain it on your data or you
can use it or you can use it pretrained
models at someone else's trend.
That's it for this session.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to go clean my kitchen,
so thanks for watching.